[Music]
hello
halloween may be long gone but we have
yet to cover the scariest thing in zelda
history the bane of 90s nintendo players
conduit of childhood trauma slayer of
parents phone bills the infamous water
temple
[Music]
the impact of this single video game
level cannot be understated just look up
the ost for this place and you'll find
countless comments and memes about the
frustration and anguish these people
felt when they first set foot into these
unholy rooms and corridors and to those
people i say yeah me too i think we all
got our ass handed to us in one way or
another during this stage of the game
but is this because it really was that
hard well to some degree yes yes it was
but not necessarily because of the
dungeon itself i think the majority of
our problems and struggles can be
chalked up to the following a many of us
were relatively young when we first
played ocarina of time b 3d gaming was
still a bit of a novel concept for many
people around this time and navigating
in three dimensions wasn't as intuitive
as it is now nowadays people make fun of
the fact that na'vi has to explain to
link how to open a door or push a block
but this kind of stuff really was
necessary for a lot of people coming
from the 16-bit era to get acclimated to
this new way of playing video games and
see ocarina of time may be a timeless
classic to many but it definitely had
some great abs built into its game
design that made things unnecessarily
frustrating and obtuse now don't get me
wrong what nintendo managed to achieve
back then is nothing short of legendary
and it's no surprise why the game is
still regarded as one of the best video
games ever made they took a formula that
was born in the 2d era and successfully
translated it to a new format overcoming
many hurdles 3d action adventure games
were challenged with all the while
inventing brand new gameplay mechanics
that are still used today albeit refined
they did it before with mario and they
did it again here but it was still the
early days of 3d gaming and obviously
they didn't get everything right on the
first try the water temple is one of
those places where some of these
limitations are emphasized like the
camera as much as the camera did its job
in wide open areas it definitely
struggled in small confined spaces
especially tight corridors and of course
when discussing the water temple it's
impossible to get around its most
prominent flaw the one issue that has
been hammered into the ground by this
point that being the way the iron boots
are utilized we all know the deal when
inside a body of water the normal boots
make you float while the iron boots make
you sink to the bottom every time you
need to swap between the two you have to
pause the game navigate to the equipment
section select the boots you want to
equip and exit the pause menu every damn
time even when playing at peak
efficiency meaning you know exactly
where to go skipping optional rooms and
utilizing diving whenever possible you
will still be hitting that pause button
around 30 times throughout the whole
experience and yes i counted and that's
excluding all the times you may need to
pause for different reasons like
changing weapons or checking the map and
like i said that's if you know what
you're doing on your first playthrough
that number is likely going to be twice
probably three times that amount or even
more this alone makes the water tempo a
drag to get through and i honestly have
no idea how it made it through play
testing back in the day i mean someone
had to have taken notice of this right
it's also no surprise then that nintendo
rectified this mistake for the 3ds
remake which made the boots function as
an item you can map to the face buttons
instead but even with this improvement i
still feel like it isn't enough to
unlock the dungeon's full potential yes
descending and ascending is now quicker
and easier but underwater traversal is
still slow and tedious your mobility is
still heavily crippled and having to
rely on the hookshot alone and not being
able to use your sword is frustrating
and it's a shame because there's a lot
to like about the water temple in fact i
would argue that underneath all the
clunkiness lies one of the smartest well
thought out and most original dungeons
in the series it's also one of only a
few 3d zelda dungeons that can compete
with the complexity of some of the
earlier 2d ones it's like a miniature
metroidvania level there's a lot of
directions to choose from and many
places you aren't able to visit until
later forcing you to keep track of where
you have or haven't been the water
temple is all about roadblocks and
demands that the player understands how
its many rooms and corridors are
connected and how the different water
levels affect those connections as the
cherry on top it also has one of the
coolest and most memorable mini bosses
in zelda dungeon history so with all
that said let's take a closer look at
the water temple how it's designed what
made it difficult and how the layout and
progression works
despite the fact that the water temple
is generally considered to be one of the
hardest dungeons to navigate the flip
side is that it's also the dungeon you
are probably the least likely to die in
the enemy variety is pretty low and they
aren't exactly among the most difficult
ones they don't do a lot of damage and
aside from some very cheap scenarios
where you're helpless to fight back
getting hit by them is mostly a matter
of impatience at best they can be
annoying especially when you're on the
water but there's enough refills to get
you through no problem you might die on
dark link i mean dark larry on your
first try when you haven't figured out
how to deal with them yet but since the
actual final boss has an absolute
pushover chances are you won't see a
game over screen very often especially
if you came prepared with medicine or
fairies in spite of its confusing layout
the water temple only has four floors
even less than the very first dungeon
inside the great deku tree but it's the
many branching paths and the way you
access one floor from another that makes
it disorienting compared to all the
other dungeons in many of these you
don't really take note of the different
floors because they don't affect each
other all that much at the very most you
might cross the same room from a
different elevation or drop down to a
chamber below but that's about the
extent of it in the water temple the
different floors are everything it
dictates where you can go how you can
get there and when you can get there
depending on the water level dropping or
raising the water will grant access to
certain rooms while at the same time
barring off others a good example being
these floating platforms even if you
manage to make your way to the third or
second floor without manipulating the
water first you still won't be able to
access some of the rooms here because
the platforms are no longer there to
support link alternatively some rooms
can only be accessed by using a bomb or
the bow and arrow which cannot be used
while submerged you enter the dungeon
from the top floor and straight into the
central chamber and this is where the
intimidation factor of the water temple
immediately becomes apparent most of
ocarina of times dungeons have a central
chamber all of which have multiple exits
and entrance ways for instance the
forest temple has seven the spirit
temple has six seven if you count the
hidden door behind the statue's face
which you won't find out about until the
very end including the entrance the
water temple has twice that amount 14
possible ways of either entering or
exiting the main chamber and there's
also an additional space inside the
central pillar which houses the only way
in and out of the basement so yeah it's
no wonder why people were a bit
overwhelmed from my own experience the
water temple has four distinct phases
there's the where do i go face the key
phase the boss key phase and finishing
up with the boss fight the first phase
as the name elegantly suggests is the
initial moment after first entering the
dungeon when you have no idea where to
even start so many doors so many
hallways to choose from especially on
the first playthrough it can be pretty
overwhelming but when you take a step
back take a breath and look at the
bigger picture you'll quickly find that
with a bit of methodical exploration the
dungeon does give you some direction
right off the bat only one out of four
doorways on the top floor is accessible
and this one path doesn't even lead to
anything except a block you can pull and
doing so will obstruct the hallway
behind it it is advised that you do this
by the way as it will save some time
later on but anyway yeah a dead end
right away so you head back to the
central room with the third floor
eliminated the only option that remains
is to go down and go down we shall the
second floor is almost as useless as the
third floor at this stage but if you
want to be a rebel you can get the
compass early since one of the four
doorways is accessible whether submerged
or not but this path only leads into one
room containing the compass and nothing
else and never has to be revisited again
after so all that leaves is the first
floor which is where most of the early
progression takes place like i said as
intimidating as the dungeon can feel
when first entering it does actually
guide you in a certain direction and
automatically funnels you towards the
bottom drawing you down floor by floor
by process of elimination once at the
bottom you again only have one way to go
the other four pathways either lead to
an immediate dead end or are completely
blocked altogether this one requires a
bomb which doesn't work on the water
this one can only be accessed with a
long shot and the other two cannot be
reached not without the floating
platforms i mentioned earlier which are
still floating on the third floor so all
that leaves us is this room which is
also where we meet up with princess ruto
this room is also quite genius because
it acts as your first test to see if you
understand the central mechanic of the
dungeon and the consequences the
different water levels have it's sort of
a miniature version of the central
chamber it too has three floors with
each floor granting or preventing access
to a room depending on the water level
ruto will explain that you'll be able to
manipulate the water to three different
levels after which she guides you up to
the third floor but as you drift upwards
you'll be able to catch a glimpse of the
second floor which shows a cracked wall
you're currently unable to blow up
because again bombs don't work on the
water at least not until twilight
princess what i find respectable about
the water temple is that it lets you
make these kinds of connections on your
own there's enough time between
observing that cracked wall on the
second floor and gaining access to the
second water level that you could
potentially forget about it and get
stumped later on there's no reminders no
companions popping up and being like oh
look at that cracked wall i wonder what
that's all about in fact for a companion
that's so often criticized and memed
about because of her intrusive nature
she sure is quiet during this dungeon
and thank god
it respects your intelligence and trust
that you'll make a mental note out of it
and still be able to recall it by the
time you raise the water to the second
floor so as you reach the third floor
you'll find the first panel with which
to manipulate the water level in this
case draining it all the way down to the
first floor there's also an additional
room leading to the map and i think it's
no coincidence that they give you the
map and compass fairly early on as it's
definitely one of those dungeons where
they are almost crucial on the first
playthrough speaking of the map i do
have to go on a brief tangent here
because as nice as it is to have and it
definitely is i do have one issue with
the way it works and this has everything
to do with the way it displays certain
rooms there's quite a lot of cases where
the same room will show up on multiple
floors now for some rooms like the
central chamber this does make sense as
it spans across different floors it's an
important aspect about it but for a room
like this for example it really doesn't
notice how as you submerge and resurface
even slightly the map will constantly
swap between the basement level and the
first floor even though this room
doesn't really have anything to do with
the basement nor is it accessible from
there the ceiling is also not
particularly high but apparently the map
still finds it necessary to include the
room on two different floors this
creates a lot of duplicate rooms on the
map and makes it more confusing than it
needs to be i think it would have been
better if they just kept the rooms
visible only on the floors where they
are relevant even if you're technically
dipping slightly below or above set
floor just because this room has a
bottomless pit that stretches all the
way to the bottom of the dungeon does it
really need to be shown on every floor
anyway from here we entered the key
phase because as you've noticed we
haven't collected one single key up to
this point with a total of 6 the water
temple has one of the highest key counts
out of all ocarina's dungeons rivaled
only by the fire temple which has eight
but it's the way you collect them that
makes the water temple stand out and the
majority are collected and spent in the
first half of the dungeon before
obtaining the key item the entire goal
of this phase is to somehow find your
way back to the third floor raise the
water back to the third level as well so
the platform is there while also being
in possession of two keys when you get
there the doors to the second and third
water panel both require a key as well
so that's a total of four keys you need
to collect before you can even reach the
dungeon item these four keys are located
here two on the first floor one in the
basement and one on the second floor
behind that cracked wall i mentioned
earlier the tricky part is that if you
miss even one of these four keys you'll
never be able to get to the dungeon item
of course that goes without saying but
if you're unlucky you'll also have to
start the entire cycle all over again
because of the way the dungeon works
it's not always as easy as just diving
back down and getting the key because
remember certain doors are inaccessible
depending on the water level see you
can't access the second panel while the
water is at level three you won't be
able to get there and even if you could
the ocarina doesn't work on the water
for obvious reasons
likewise you cannot get to the first
panel from level 2 as the water isn't
high enough to reach it you always have
to go from 3 to 1 then 2 back to 3 so on
and so forth so say for instance you get
to the 3rd floor only to realize that
you forgot the key behind that cracked
wall which embarrassingly enough
actually did happen to me on a recent
live stream wait there's not a key door
there right oh there is i forgot a key
this means having to dive all the way
back down float up to the first panel
lowering the water to the first floor
entering the central pillar to get to
the second panel raise the water to the
second floor dive back down to the first
floor float back up this room to the
second floor blow up the wall and obtain
the key and then of course you need to
go back up to raise the water to the
third floor and you're back on track if
you know exactly what you're doing you
only have to change the water level a
total of six times throughout the whole
experience but on a first playthrough
you won't know how many keys you'll need
to move forward it's not like you can
guess that there's another locked door
right behind this one so you'll likely
be repeating this cycle at least one or
two times before getting to the long
shot not to mention that not all keys
are easy to find there's of course the
key sneakily hidden in the basement
speaking of which this is also where i
want to make a quick comparison between
the n64 original and the 3ds version
because this is one example where i feel
like they definitely overcorrected the
entrance to the basement is hidden
underneath this block and becomes
accessible when you raise the water to
the second floor and the block floats
upwards and yeah it's a pretty sneaky
location to hide a key but it's not like
it's impossible to find out when the
cutscene plays on the n64 the camera
follows the block as it rises upwards
and if you're a little bit observant you
can actually see the entrance if you
would check the map it also clearly
shows that there's another room right
below this one it doesn't spell it out
for you but it's also not as convoluted
as some people claim it to be but i
guess many people disagreed because for
the 3ds they totally removed the
challenge not only did they change the
angle of the camera during the cutscene
but it also literally zooms in on the
entrance as if to say over here dummy it
completely destroys any incentive from
the player to find out on their own they
might as well have added a giant arrow
and a neon sign there as well i
definitely had a lot of trouble with the
water tempo as a kid but i still vividly
remember how clever i felt when i found
this out on my own on the n64 it was
subtle but not unfair here it cannot
even be classified as a discovery the
game does it for you the same could be
said about these impossible to miss
glowing guidelines which weren't there
on the n64 they're meant to guide you to
the different water panels and although
i find them unnecessary they don't
bother me as much because it's not like
the water panels were hard to find on
the n64 either anyway once you have all
the keys you need it's a straight shot
to dark link and subsequently the long
shot you send your darker half back to
the abyss claim the long shot and
congratulations you're about 60 of the
way there from here you'll automatically
be guided back to a room on the first
floor you've already visited before you
also collect the second to last key on
the way there which is impossible to
miss so now you're essentially back in
familiar territory but with no guidance
where to go next accessing the boss
chamber only requires two things the
long shot and the boss key this next
phase can be a bit of a hassle if you
just mindlessly start running around and
exhausting every option but if you use
the map you would see that there's
really only three remaining pathways you
haven't visited one leading to the boss
and two leading to a chest one
containing the final small key and the
other the boss key it's actually pretty
straightforward at the very most you
might go after the wrong chest first as
the map doesn't differentiate between a
normal chest and the boss chest if you
happen to go after the boss key first
you'll quickly realize that the very
very last door of this section is locked
and this is really where i started to
realize my incompetence and impatience
back when i first played ocarina of time
because i'm pretty sure this is exactly
what happened to me i would stumble upon
this final locked door and be like oh my
god head back into the dungeon
mindlessly run around like an idiot
until i finally found the last key on
the whim i barely looked at the map if
at all i don't know maybe i was just a
dumb kid but the fact that so many
people have such bad memories of this
place gives me a shimmer of hope that
maybe a lot of us were dumb and
impatient back when we were kids and
it's not just me so yeah you get the
last key it's behind that block we
pulled at the beginning you get the boss
key go back to the third floor enter the
boss room and defeat the boss the end
and that's the water temple for you was
it hard well yes and no compared to most
other dungeons in ocarina it's
definitely a significant step up in
difficulty the others don't require you
to backtrack to this extent sure there's
some keys that are hidden quite well and
you might have to go back and get it but
it doesn't happen very often during the
key phase and boss key phase especially
you will be backtracking quite a lot on
a first playthrough and there's a lot of
roadblocks to keep in the back of your
mind for later this is why i stated that
the water temple is a bit like a
miniature metroidvania stage and might
also explain why some people had great
difficulty while others barely had any
trouble with it at all i think it boils
down to experience if you grew up
playing games like super metroid then
getting lost checking maps and
backtracking are natural for you and the
water temple was probably small potatoes
but if you're someone like me who mostly
stuck to mario and pokemon prior to
picking up ocarina of time you probably
lack the experience to explore
methodically heck ocarina of time was my
very first zelda so i didn't even have
the experience from the older games at
that point so yes for some of us the
water temple really was that hard but it
definitely doesn't mean that the dungeon
is bad gameplay wise it is and now numa
even apologized for it around the time
of ocarina of time 3d's release but he
also apologized for the overall design
of the dungeon itself and that's where
i'm like no don't apologize for the
dungeon design it's good the way all
these mechanics work together the water
levels the platforms the maze-like
interior it's brilliant it's one of the
most clever designs in the series and
there's a reason why more and more
critics have come forward to express
their appreciation for it it's a dungeon
that demands patience if you run around
like a headless chicken without thinking
about where you're gonna go and why
you're gonna have a bad time but if you
take your time and explore methodically
utilize the map and learn to understand
its mechanics and layout it's one of the
most satisfying dungeons to conquer the
only thing holding it back and unlocking
its true potential is the clunky
underwater controls 3ds improvements are
not i'm convinced that if ocry enough
time had similar underwater controls as
twilight princess being able to swim up
and down freely instead of only relying
on the iron boots using your sword
underwater etc this dungeon wouldn't
nearly be as divisive and may have even
been regarded as one of the best in the
series by almost everyone because
mechanically it really is anyway that
wraps up the video i want to thank
everyone for their viewership support
and all that good jazz a shout out to my
amazing discord community and a big
thanks to my patreons and channel
members you are all amazing as always
and that is all for now this is dawn
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
foreign